the choice in this election is a choice
between taking our government back from
the special interest or surrendering
really the last scrap of Independence to
the total and complete control of people
like the Clintons those are the stakes
Hillary Clinton wants to be President
but she doesn't have the temperament or
as Bernie Sanders said very strongly the
judgment to be President she does not
have the judgment she believes she
believes she's entitled to the office
her campaign slogan is I'm with her you
know what my response is to that I'm
with you the American people
thank you very much she thinks it's all
about her I know it's all about you I
know it's all about making America great
again for all Americans all Americans
our country lost its way when it stopped
putting the American people really first
we have to go back to putting American
people first we got here because we
switched from a policy of Americanism
focusing on what's good for America's
middle class to a policy of globalism
focusing on how to make money for large
corporations who can move their wealth
and workers to foreign countries all to
the detriment of the American worker and
the American economy itself we reward
companies for offshoring and we punish
companies for doing business in America
and keeping our workers employed they
get punished this is not a rising tide
that lifts all boats this is a wave of
globalism that wipes out our middle
class and our jobs along with it we need
reform and we have to reform our
economic system so that once again we
can all succeed together and America can
become rich again we have to make
America rich again
and that's what i mean by america first
our country will be better off when we
start making our own products again
bringing our once-great manufacturing
capabilities back to the shores i mean
we have to bring our manufacturers back
to the United States desperately needed
desperately we need those jobs and we
need it even from our psyche one of the
really great things and one of the first
major bills that george washington
signed was amazing when i saw this for
the first time the encouragement and
protection of manufacturing in America
our first Republican President Abraham
Lincoln warned us by saying the
abandonment of the protective policy by
the American government will produce
want and ruin among our people in other
words we have to protect our country I
have decided and visited cities and
towns across America all across America
and seeing the devastation caused by the
trade policies of Bill and Hillary
Clinton and its total devastation all
over New York all over Pennsylvania all
over New England all over the country
Hillary Clinton supported Bill Clinton's
disasters and totally disastrous NAFTA
just like she supported China's entrance
into the World Trade Organization we've
lost nearly one-third of our
manufacturing jobs since these two
Hillary backed agreements were signed
among the worst we've ever done among
the most destructive agreements we've
ever signed our trade deficit with China
sword forty percent during Hillary
Clinton's time as Secretary of State a
disgraceful performance for which she
should not be congratulated but rather
scorned then she left China so true
then she left China and what happened is
billions and billions of dollars in our
intellectual property and China has
taken it and it's a crime which is
continuously going on and it's going on
right now they are stealing billions and
billions of dollars of our intellectual
property Hillary Clinton gave china
millions of jobs and our best jobs and
effectively let China completely rebuild
itself in return Hillary Clinton got
rich the book Clinton cash by Peter
Schweitzer documents how Bill and
Hillary used the State Department to
orig their family and America's and add
America's expense she gets rich making
you poor
here is a quote from the book at the
center of US policy toward China was
Hillary Clinton at this critical time
for us China relations Bill Clinton gave
her a number of speeches that were
underwritten by the Chinese government
and its supporters these funds were paid
to the Clintons bank account directly
while Hilary was negotiating with China
on behalf of the united states tel me
folks does that work she sold out our
workers and our country for Beijing
Hillary Clinton has also been the
biggest promoter of the trans-pacific
partnership which will ship millions
more of our jobs overseas and give up
congressional power to an international
foreign commission now because I have
pointed out why it would be such a
disastrous deal she's pretending that
she's against it she's given and deleted
as you know and most people have heard
about this have we ever heard about her
deleting anything no I don't think so
she deleted the entire record from her
book and deletion is something she
really does know something about because
she's deleted at least 30,000 emails
which by the way should be able to be
found should be able to be found because
the government I will say I've always
heard you can never really delete an
email so it should be able to be fun if
they really want to find them but I
don't think they want to find them this
is the latest Clinton coverup and it
doesn't change anything if she is
elected president she will adopt the
trans-pacific partnership and we will
lose millions of jobs and our economic
independence for good she'll do this and
just as she has betrayed the American
worker run traded every single stage of
a career and it will be even worse than
the Clintons NAFTA deal and I never
thought it could get worse than that we
will lose jobs we will lose employment
we will lose taxes
we'll lose everything we will lose our
country but they have to be great
we don't make great deals anymore but we
will once I become president I promise
you
it's not just our economy that's been
corrupted but our foreign policy to the
Hillary Clinton foreign policy has cost
America thousands of lives and trillions
and trillions of dollars and unleashed
Isis across the world no Secretary of
State has been more wrong more often and
in more places than Hillary Clinton her
decision spread death destruction and
terrorism everywhere she touched among
the victims of our late ambassador Chris
Stevens I mean she what she did with him
was absolutely horrible he was left
helpless to die as Hillary Clinton
soundly slept in her bed that's right
when the phone rang as per the
commercial at three o'clock in the
morning Hillary Clinton was sleeping
ambassador Stevens and his staff in
Libya made hundreds and hundreds of
requests for security they were
desperate they needed help Hillary
Clinton State Department refused them
all she started the war that put them in
Libya denied him the security he asked
for then left him there to die to cover
her tracks Hillary lied about the video
being the cause of death the famous
video all a lie another Hillary lie
here's what one of the victim's mother
had to say I want the whole world to
know it she lied to my face and you know
this person cannot be President she
cannot be President
in 2009 before Hillary Clinton was sworn
in it was a different world Libya was
cooperating Iraq was seeing a reduction
in violence believe it or not Syria was
under control Iran was being choked by
sanctions Egypt was governed by a
friendly regime that honored zits peace
treaty with Israel something very nice
because by the way Israel has been
totally mistreated by the United States
Isis wasn't even on the map fast forward
to 2013 in just four years Secretary
Clinton managed almost single-handedly
destabilize the entire Middle East her
invasion of Libya handed the country
over to Isis the barbarians thanks to
Hillary Clinton Iran is now the dominant
Islamic power in the Middle East and on
the road to nuclear weapons Hillary
Clinton support for violent regime
change in syria has thrown the country
into one of the bloodiest civil wars
anyone has ever seen while giving Isis a
launching pad for terrorism against the
West she helped force out a friendly
regime in Egypt and replace it with the
radical Muslim Brotherhood the Egyptian
military has retaken control but Clinton
has opened the Pandora's box of radical
Islam then there was the disastrous
strategy of announcing our departure
from Iraq handing large parts of the
country over to Isis and the ISIS
killers Isis threatens us today because
of the decisions Hillary Clinton has
made along with President Obama Isis
also threatens peaceful Muslims across
the Middle East and peaceful Muslims
across the world who have been terribly
victimized by horrible brutality and who
only want to raise their kids in peace
and safety in short
in short Hillary Clinton's try out for
the presidency has produced one deadly
foreign policy disaster after another
one by one they're all bad she's
virtually done nothing right she's
virtually done nothing good it all
started with her bad judgment in
supporting the war in Iraq in the first
place though I was not in government
service I was among the earliest to
criticize the rush to war and yes even
before the war ever started but Hillary
Clinton learned nothing from Iraq
because when she got into power she
couldn't wait to rush us off to war in
Libya she lacks the temperament and the
judgment and the competence to lead our
country she should not be president
under any circumstance
in the words of a Secret Service agent
posted outside the Oval Office somebody
that saw her a lot and knows her
probably better than almost anybody she
simply lacks the integrity and
temperament to serve in the office from
the bottom of my soul I know this to be
true her leadership style volcanic
impulsive disdainful and disdainful of
the rules said for everyone else hasn't
changed one bit perhaps the most
terrifying thing about Hillary Clinton's
foreign policy is that she refuses to
acknowledge the threat posed by radical
Islam in fact Hillary Clinton supports a
radical five hundred and fifty percent
increase in Syrian refugees coming into
the United States and that's an increase
over President Obama's already high
number under her plan we would admit
hundreds of thousands of refugees from
the most dangerous countries on earth
with no way to screen who they are what
they are what they believe where they
come from already hundreds of recent
immigrants and their children have been
convicted of terrorist activity inside
the United States the father of the
Orlando shooter was a Taliban supporter
from Afghanistan one of the most
repressive anti-gay and anti-woman
regimes on earth I only want to admit
people who share our values and love our
people
Barry Clinton wants to bring in people
who believe women should be enslaved and
gays put to death maybe her motivation
lies among the more than 1,000 foreign
donations Hillary failed to disclose
while at the State Department Hillary
Clinton may be the most corrupt person
ever to seek the presidency of the
United States
thank you
thank you
so true
thank you here's some of really what we
learned from the book in addition to
what we've already discussed a foreign
telecom giant face possible State
Department sanctions for providing
technology to Iran and other oppressive
regimes so what did this company do for
the first time ever they decided to pay
bill klijn 750 thousand dollars for a
single speech the Clintons got their
cash the telecom company escaped all
sanctions Hillary Clinton State
Department approved the transfer of
twenty percent of america's uranium
holdings to Russia while nine investors
in the deal funneled 145 million dollars
to the Clinton Foundation 145 million
dollars hillary clinton appointed a top
donor to a national security bored with
cop secret access even though he had no
national security credentials although
he did make a very large campaign
contribution hillary clinton accepted 58
thousand dollars in jewelry from the
government of brunei when she was
Secretary of State plus millions more
for her foundation the Sultan of Brunei
has pushed oppressive Sharia law
including the punishment by death and
stoning if you happen to be gay the
government of Brunei also stands to be
one of the biggest beneficiary of
Hillary's trans-pacific partnership
which he would absolutely approve if
given the chance Hillary Clinton's book
and just think of this the book talks
about it but Hillary took 25
million dollars from Saudi Arabia and
much more from others where being gay is
also punishable by death Hillary took
millions from Kuwait Qatar Oman and many
other countries that horribly abused
women and the LGBT citizens to cover up
her corrupt dealings Hillary illegally
stashed her State Department emails on a
private server she's under investigation
but it seems like nothing's going to
happen even though other people who have
done similar things but much at a much
lower level their lives have been
destroyed it's a rigged system folks
it's a rigged system her server was
easily hacked by foreign governments
perhaps even by her financial backers in
communist China I'm sure they have it
putting all of America and our citizens
in danger great danger then there are
the 33,000 emails she deleted well we
may not know what's in those deleted
emails our enemies probably know every
single one of them so they probably now
have a blackmail file over someone who
wants to be the president of the United
States this fact alone disqualifies her
from the presidency we can't hand over
our government to someone whose deepest
darkest secrets may be in the hands of
our enemies can't do it
national security is also immigration
security and Hillary once neither
Hillary Clinton has put forward the most
radical immigration platform in the
history of the United States she's
pledged to grand mass amnesty and in a
first 100 days in virtually all
immigration enforcement and thus create
totally open borders for the United
States totally open borders and by the
way 16,500 Border Patrol agents have
endorsed Donald Trump first time in the
history that they've endorsed
the first victims of her radical
policies will be poor African American
and Hispanic workers who need jobs
they're also the ones that she will hurt
the most by far let me share with you a
letter our campaign received from
Marianne Mendoza she lost her amazing
son police sergeant Brandon Mendoza
after he was killed by an illegal
immigrant because of open borders and
policies supported by Hillary Clinton
sadly the mendoza family is just one of
thousands who have suffered the same
fate here's an excerpt from mrs.
Mendoza's letter Hillary Clinton who
already has the blood of so many on her
hands is now announcing that she is
willing to put each and every one of our
lives in harm's way an open-door policy
to criminals and terrorists to enter our
country Hillary is not concerned about
you or I she is only concerned about the
power of the presidency and the power
that it would bring she needs to go to
prison to pay for the crimes that she's
already committed against our country
that's from mrs. Mendoza Hillary also
wants to spend hundreds of billions of
dollars to settle Middle Eastern
refugees in the United States on top of
the current record level of immigration
that we already have for the amount of
money Hillary Clinton would like to
spend on refugees we could rebuild every
inner-city America
Keller is Wall Street immigration agenda
will keep immigrant communities poor and
unemployed Americans totally out of work
she can't claim to care about
african-american and Hispanic workers
when she wants to bring in millions of
new low wage earners to compete against
them and win against them because the
system is rigged against our people here
are a few things a trump administration
will do for the Americans and for the
American people but for our country
number one the first hundred days I will
appoint judges who will uphold the
Constitution of the United States
Hillary Clinton's radical judges will
virtually abolish the Second Amendment
can't let that happen I will change
immigration rules to give unemployed
americans an opportunity to fill good
really good paying jobs we don't have
good jobs anymore these will be good
paying jobs will stand up to countries
that cheat on trade of which there are
many will cancel rules and regulations
that send jobs overseas and everywhere
else but our country the lift
restrictions on energy production we
will repeal and replace job-killing
Obamacare it is a total disaster
we'll pass massive tax reform to create
millions of new jobs and lower taxes for
everyone and we are by the way the
highest taxed nation in the world please
remember that we're going to impose
tough new ethics rules to restore
dignity to the office of the secretary
of state there is one common theme in
all of these reforms it's going to be
America first this is why stakes in
November are so great on Election Day
the politicians stand trial before the
people the voters are the jury their
ballots are the verdict we don't need or
want another Clinton or Obama we just
can't take it anymore so bad for our
country and our people
come November the American people will
have a chance to issue a verdict when
the politicians that have sacrificed
their security betrayed their prosperity
and sold out their country and I mean
totally sold out their country it will
have a chance to vote for a new agenda
with big dreams bold ideas and enormous
possibilities for the American people
Hillary Clinton's message is old and
tired her message is that things can't
change my message is that things have to
change and that this is our one chance
and may be our only chance to do that
change and if we don't do it now folks I
don't know that we'll ever ever have
another chance we have to have change
but real change not Obama change
Americans are the people that tamed the
worst that dugout the Panama Canal that
send satellites across the solar system
that built the Great dams and so much
more then we we really started thinking
small something happened something
happened to our mentality we started
thinking small we stopped believing in
what America could do and became reliant
on other countries other people and
other institutions we lost our sense of
purpose and daring but that's not who we
are
come this November we can bring America
back bigger and better and stronger than
ever before we will build the greatest
infrastructure on the planet earth the
roads and railways and airports of
tomorrow our military our military which
is totally depleted will have the best
technology and the finest equipment we
will bring it back to the way that it
must be strong strong strong massive new
factories will come roaring into our
country breathing life and hope into our
communities inner cities which have been
horribly abused by Hillary Clinton and
the Democrat Party will finally finally
finally be rebuilt
construction is what I know I say nobody
knows it better the real wages for our
workers have not been raised for 18
years but these wages will start going
up along with new jobs jobs jobs
Hillary's massive taxation regulation
and open borders will destroy jobs and
drive down wages for everyone and that's
what's been happening and that's why
you're seeing so many people coming to
our rallies and so much unbelievable
support we're also going to be
supporting our police and law
enforcement we can never forget the
great job they do
thank you I'm also going to appoint
great Supreme Court justice is so
important one of the most important
factors in this election but have many
appointments could be as many as five
probably will be three could be for one
of the really big factors in this
election we are going to appoint Supreme
Court justices who will be outstanding
outstanding so important our country is
going to start working again jobs people
are going to start working again parents
are going to start dreaming big for
their children again including parents
in our inner cities
thank you Americans Americans the people
that we love Americans America first
make our country great again Americans
are going to start believing in the
future of our country we are going to
make America rich again we are going to
make America safe again thing to make
America great again and great again for
everyone everyone thank you very much
thank you very much every been pushing
thank you
ladies and gentlemen please remain
seated until mr. Trump and the Trump
family have departed thank you
to make him the MVP I still think if
they would have if they would have if
they wouldn't have won LeBron still
would have been the MVP of the series he
was the most consistent player
do you hear like a crack no I do it's
not that bad going again I don't think
so it's all right out it
yeah do you think about just how many
people are from like here yeah yeah this
is like what one-tenth of the graph yeah
you
the other issue to
I saw a picture of the way is gonna I
think they're going for deep go to d
it's like for crops all right there hard
yeah why would they do that is because
it is driving or the car Oh is he really
so for yeah uh let's see why I mean at
least that's the picture that you took
yeah line of cars uh-huh there was four
wide was he driving as you know he
doesn't you know what when he's driving
so i'm guessing Kevin lover cheers Smith
or no I think Terry Smith's on the end
so you'd be covering over twisting so
those for all coming up together the
same line I know yeah unless it was just
a picture that like I said they're all
lined up behind him too so right it
seemed like that was Holly
we're not gonna be able to see no like I
can't really see anything
hey Kelly
sorry
no I didn't find one will be finalised
hitter tomorrow yeah thanks yeah I want
to let them know when the parade comes
by we're not gonna be able to do it play
that play hey Kelly it's Flanagan can
you hear me okay all right hey Kelly can
you hear me
hey Cheyenne you put it on me for a
second i want to get their attention hey
Kelly
hey guys he let them know can you call
the assignment desk let them know the
mark and I we really can to apply by
play we can't see the cars we're 75
yards back by the truck because it yeah
thanks I mean we we may have just tell
me dance come those about to toss back
quickly I mean we can't do we can't see
yeah hey Kelly
hey you have any beer this is the lion
liberal media right here we're hoping
you had beer huh we're hoping you had
the beer oh no I'm Amish hey Kelly it's
Flanagan can you hear me
she a torpedo back to me okay stay with
them and I said no they can't see
anything right so then they're aware
okay thank you
you